the 2020 presidential election is now
less than a year away and the Democratic
nomination that race is still wide open
a recent poll from the key state of Iowa
shows the top Democratic candidates are
all bunched up at the top Elizabeth
Warren Bernie Sanders Pete Budaj and Joe
Biden all within a few points of each
other and O'Keefe is in Des Moines at
good morning so what does this poll say
to you well Tony what's happening here
is a little bit different than what's
going on nationally because Buddha judge
is starting to spend millions of dollars
he raised over the summer but the Biden
campaign points out they've raised
millions as well and they've just
launched an advertising campaign they
think will help one thing we noticed
over the weekend the candidates are
starting to go after each other a little
more it all started with something Mayor
Buddha judge had to say you see it's
coming into focus you and warrant yeah
and certainly a world where we're
getting somewhere is that world where
it's coming down to the two of us
indiana mayor buddha's judge is indeed
on the rise here in iowa but he's not
alone with new polling showing that
former Vice President Joe Biden and
Senators Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders maintain a grip on the top spots
in the race for president on Sunday mu
de jedge backtracked telling CBS n it's
not yet a two way race yeah that didn't
come out right I can't remember the
exact context for that but not before
other candidates shot down his theory
it's naive for him to think that at this
point but that the debate of this
election has been determined that it's
very important that anyone wants to be a
leader has the ability to walk and talk
with every community that's a knock on
Buddha judges weak standing with black
and Latino voters candidates like who
Leon Castro say the party needs a
nominee who can get them to the polls if
that person can't connect with those
communities they simply should not be at
the top of the ticket
it's too risky meanwhile the top issue
of conversation this weekend health care
and Warren's plan to pay for it which
would divert the funds employers
currently pay private health care
companies to the government and
increased taxes on the wealthy it
doesn't raise taxes on anybody but
billionaires and you know what the
ability
nurse can afford it and I don't call
their middle-class moderates like Joe
Biden are skeptical and say that they
would instead just build on Obamacare
even Bernie Sanders the architect of
Medicare for all admits that he would
raise taxes on people to pay for the
plan but that ultimately your co-pays
and deductibles would go down